in high school there are four types of
people students who don't try
students that do bad students that do
good and students that try hard
as you can see by the title i fell into
the last category
throughout high school i took 11 ap
exams and 5 dual credit classes
and at the end of the day i ended up
with a gpa
of 5.7906 out of 5 meaning
i averaged a 97.7906 throughout my
honors and ap classes
which landed me a spot of number 3 out
of well over 800 students
but at the end of the day i'm not too
sure it was worth it
and here's why
[Music]
starting off we have to take a look at
the relationship between our work and
our results
the thing is the relationship between
work and results
is not linear but more like a square
root graph as suggested by the pareto
principle
the pareto principle which is more well
known as the 80 20 principle
suggests that 80 of our results come
from just 20 percent of our work
so going back to school let's take a
look at a person who ranked 1
in a class of 100 people if this
individual only put in 20
of the effort he put into becoming
number one he wouldn't have ranked his
number 80
but actually number 20. and knowing that
each percentage of work is worth
less and less when it comes to results
this person could have likely just spent
50 of their efforts
and still would have likely landed into
the top 10 percent if not higher
now of course other factors do play into
this like how easily you understand your
content
and your natural understanding of
various subjects so
for your individual scenario you may be
looking at a 2060 rule or a 2090 rule
but the principle remains identical the
minority of our work accounts for the
majority of our results
considering this is spending the extra
80 percent of our effort
worth it for the last 20 of results
well in most cases the answer is no
spending 20 may not be appropriate but
in the vast majority of scenarios
spending 40
50 60 or 70 percent would allow you to
achieve
90 to 95 percent of the same things
while being significantly less demanding
this isn't that big of a deal in high
school sure
by trying harder you may be more
stressed and have less time for yourself
but for the most part it's not like you
would do something more productive with
the time
anyways however carrying this mindset
into work can really be detrimental
as it takes away from your ability to
focus on other projects
for instance let's say we have two guys
who are financial analysts
named elon and jeff elon is a great
employee
he gets his work done and causes no
issues and
he chooses to work at a mid-sized local
firm making the median salary of 80
grand
jeff on the other hand is exceptional
and is always impressing his managers
and directors
from the very first interview he knocked
the socks of management
allowing him to score a financial
analyst job at a prestigious
international firm
earning 20k above the median at 100 000
per year
being financial analysts both of these
guys are well aware of the power of
stocks
bonds and options however elon has more
time outside of work than jeff
to analyze and invest into various
stocks this
is because with elon's job it only takes
him 40 hours per week with 60 hour weeks
here and there
jeff's job however is costing him 80
plus hours per week
as he is working the heart of wall
street assuming that 80 hours a week
is 100 of one's work energy elon still
has 40 hours left to spend on
investments
but jeff has none in other words elon
spends 50 of his effort to make 80k
while jeff spends 100 of his effort to
make 100k
if elon is able to carry the same
efficiency into his investments
he'd actually be making a total of 160
thousand dollars which is 60
higher than jeff but even if he was only
half as efficient with his investments
compared to his job
he'd still be making 120 000 which is
still 20
higher than jeff not to mention elon's
income is more diverse and more likely
to grow
as he is not the max at his job or with
its investments
now that was just an example but it
happens to be pretty close to reality
elon musk runs two of the largest
companies in the world
and he is able to pull it off because he
spends his time in the places that have
the largest impacts on either company
he's not going to be trying to perfect
laning rockets when tesla is going
through production hell
and he's not worried about tesla stock
plunging when spacex is about to launch
humans to the iss
while this sounds self-explanatory it's
not so clear in our day-to-day lives
as we neglect external opportunities on
a daily basis
pouring all our effort into school or
one job
and as for jeff bezos well he literally
embodies the example
after college jeff bezos worked at a
hedge fund company
named sean co and he likely poured
everything into it
as he became vice president in just four
years
however as we already know he realized
it wasn't worth his time
leading him to quit and start amazon as
for how this applies to me
and high school well i've been doing
youtube for 3 years now
but till recently nearly all of my
videos were published over the summer
when i had more time
taking a look at my social blade graph
we can see a peak during the last two
summers that quickly fade away after
school starts
as i get back into try harding in school
now this
isn't to say that i should have
completely dropped a ball on school to
pursue youtube
however if i aim to be a great student
rather than an exceptional one
i could have saved a lot of effort and i
could have spent this extra effort onto
youtube
it likely won't be the three videos a
week that i'm able to post over the
summer
but it would be significantly higher
than no videos a week that ended up
happening by try harding in school
the truth is most of my extra efforts at
school make no tangible difference in my
educational outlook
while consistent effort towards youtube
throughout the year could have
significantly upgraded my chances
at youtube growth but that's not the
main reason i regret going so hard at
high school
the main reason i would have changed my
approach to high school
is the motive behind it most people who
try hard in school
fall into three categories there's those
who try biggest of their parents
those who try for social clout and then
there are those who do it for the money
working towards a high-paying job is the
most noble of the three
as it's in hopes of self-improvement but
really
all three of these approaches are flawed
working to meet parents expectations or
social clout
really needs no explanation as to why
they're flawed
however as for trying to get a
high-paying job
the issue with this is not that most of
these people don't achieve their goal
most of these people do eventually get
great jobs paying well into six figures
if not multiple six figures however
virtually all these people also fall
into 85 percent of people who hate their
jobs
thus they have failed at the more
important goals of work-life balance as
well as job satisfaction
personally i didn't think school would
have the biggest impact on my future
income
nor did i have much pressure from my
parents the main reason i try harder in
school was simply for social reasons
it made me feel cool and raise my ego
but there's no question that those are
meaningless
superficial metrics that will fade away
the day high school ends
and that's why i regret tryharding in
high school i could have spent much less
effort
and my results wouldn't have really
changed i could have spent the saved
effort into other endeavors that would
likely have a larger impact
and it's not like i was trying because i
love school
now if you're part of the minority who
actually loves the material and not try
harding for the external reasons
that's outstanding and you should keep
doing whatever it is you're doing
but for the rest of us whether we like
to admit it or not
we are heavily fueled by superficial
reasons and i think we should take it
back
just a notch don't be a bad student but
simply settle
being a good student or a good employee
and
with the extra time you have pursue
projects that you're actually passionate
about
whether you're starting a business
growing a real estate portfolio
or investing in the market one day you
might even be able to turn your full
focus onto
side projects at which point you can try
hard as
much as you want as this effort is
coming from the heart
as opposed to brain but that's just my
experience drop a like if you guys agree
and of course consider subscribing to
see more questions largely answered
but until then i'm hari and i'll see you
guys on the next one
you